it's possibly the worst time of the year
to try to stop the spread of a virus in
China hundreds of millions of people are
Criss crossing the country this week to
celebrate the Lunar New Year with family
since its outbreak in the city of Wuhan
the deadly virus has jumped a number of
international borders prompting
large-scale screening measures at
airports bus and railway stations
containing the virus is an absolute
priority as quickly as possible because
they are fears that the virus could
mutate the evidence shows that the
disease is currently transmitted through
the respiratory tract and there is the
possibility of a viral mutation in an
attempt to minimize the risk of
contagion during the current travel rush
a number of Airlines and railway
companies have announced they'll wave
cancellation fees for trips to and from
Wuhan the city's mayor has also warned
against travel to the epicenter of the
outbreak and urged the people who are
already there to stay
some people have canceled their trips
due to the current situation but it's
unlikely to stop the majority from
traveling for many Chinese the Lunar New
Year holiday is the only chance they get
to see their relatives all year Chinese
state television reports that the death
toll in the outbreak of a new corona
virus in China has now jumped to 17 with
nearly 500 confirmed cases well there is
now growing fear that the disease could
spread and several countries are
screening transit points for ill
passengers well the virus is on the move
and that's what makes it so scary Hong
Kong and Macau have confirmed infections
other regions have also reported a
handful of cases Thailand Taiwan South
Korea and Japan and also the US while
the World Health Organization is meeting
in Geneva to decide whether to declare a
global public health emergency well
health authorities have traced the virus
now to a seafood market in Wuhan while
they're still trying to figure out the
exact source and how it is adapting but
they have confirmed human-to-human
transmission the evidence shows that the
disease is currently transmitted through
the respiratory tract and there is the
possibility of a viral mutation all
right joining me now for more on this
story is dr. Mohammad Munir a virologist
doctor so good of you to join us from
Lancashire one of China's top health
officials that we just heard there
announced that the virus could mutate
now as a member of general public
hearing mutate that sounds really scary
does this mean that it will make it more
contagious well matter of the fact is
that viruses always mutate they have a
tendency to change their shape they
after Nancy to evolve so that's not new
the important thing is that whether that
change over that mutation would have any
impact onto the disease outcome what the
severity would be increased so if we
look on to the history of these viruses
like source and Mars which are relative
to these corona viruses there are highly
probability that these were
if they mutate they will be more stable
they will be more fitter and they will
sustain in the population for a longer
time now doctor the World Health
Organization is holding an emergency
meeting as we speak it is rare for the
w-h-o to declare a global health
emergency it has not done that as of yet
but when it does do that what does it
actually mean so since the placement of
the the rule wh-whoa has only placed the
emergency five times in the last 20
years and all those have been on viruses
so in the current situation although the
virus is emerging in all dimensions from
England to overseas and the human to
human transmission is there there are
relatively less chances that there would
be an emergency in place but that all
depends on what the situation will come
up and how the official will decide
today afternoon but there are relatively
less chances that emergency would be put
in place now dr. Munir of course this is
the flu season so how can we tell
whether we have contracted this a very
contagious disease what are the symptoms
of the virus and how can it be treated
so the virus itself cause pneumonia like
symptoms there would be a problem with
the breathing there would be in
pneumonia
there would be fever so whenever these
kind of situations comes in there is
literally no treatment or a vaccine
available at this moment the only
possibility is the personal hygiene
staying away from uncooked food or
direct contact with the animals and sort
of containing yourself for longer
travels or or in contact with other
healthy people so that's the only thing
that can be done at an individual level
at this moment all right dr. Mohammad
Munir joining us from a Lancaster
University sir thank you so much it to
be